So this is November's the last month of testing for 2024, also note that
November 2024 was election
year. So just bear that in mind as well. Let's take a little bit of a look.
What was our data like?
So return 20, 22% for that month, but also please take in mind that we're
basically risking $20,000 a trade.
So it's really like 10% in terms of percentage. Can we look up a percentage?
Oh, it's still going to show us the same, no, no.
(silence)
Sure.
So 22%, so it's not my right.
I don't understand this.
I'm not sure how it's tagging.
It's really annoying.
(silence)
So I'm pretty sure it doesn't consider break-evens or postures and stuff.
Yeah, honestly, I wish we just kind of started the test then.
Just set the rule of just risk-wimps and of current, of total balance.
But at the end of the day, the entire process is not to be just to make
everything powerful.
It's to show you number one, how to trade the system.
Number two, all the different independent data points of the system.
So, yeah, let's just jump straight into November.
(silence)
And why shock?
I indicate it has to be set back up.
Cool, so we're going to be doing November.
This is the final month of 2024 that I would have traded.
(silence)
And...
It's also election year.
Do bear in mind this model or this specific variation of the model that we are
currently testing is...
Wait, November, we changed time.
First Sunday.
Okay, is a new model, so new in its variation.
Obviously, we have the SMC playbook, but this is just refined.
It's broken down, it's detailed for tracking purposes.
(silence)
So, it's also Friday the first, it's NFP.
I'm not going to be trading.
We're technically bearish, I think.
No, we're bullish.
I'm still not going to trade.
(silence)
Cool.
Now...
(silence)
Now, we need to change.
Because that's 1 a.m. and should be 2 a.m.
So, everything goes to...
(silence)
Awesome.
First Sunday of November.
And then I think it's like second something of March.
The time's changed, so make sure that you're adjusting for that.
The structure is...
bearish, but we have the swing highs appear, so...
Now the structure is bullish.
Again, just remember this is election month.
Monday the 4th of November.
So the 5th of November tomorrow is the election day.
So, oh no, today, sorry.
Today is the election day.
So, just be obviously very cautious.
Like, I would never trade election day.
So, I'm basically just going to factor that into my decision making process.
I'm not going to trade this day.
Hopefully it doesn't give us a set up.
Thank you.
Cool.
And the election takes place, so I think 2.
7 a.m.
Oh, okay.
So there's no immediate movement from the market.
Now that is...
that's the real movement of the election, which is a much stronger dollar.
Notice that it doesn't surprise me the real trade in activity takes place
after the key windows.
And this final move here,
probably this entire build-up to be honest with you.
Just one big inducement.
One big buy-side liquidation so that these real players can position themselves
.
In my opinion, of course.
Cool.
I do remember also they come up with some news coverage as to why the market
dropped.
So, about like some Europe had seen record highs of heat or something like that
.
Yeah, that's just a cover-up.
So we're bearish, but I need the age of heights we've taken out.
We're bearish again.
No volume.
So I said it's 7, we're bearish.
There's no shift in there, no shift in there.
There's a shift there though.
Bearish, eel, spare.
And the shift comes at these lows.
What time is it?
It's 4.45, and it's the seventh balance of trade.
Fed interest rate decisions.
So I'll be very cautious of that.
The first day, first election day.
There'll be an up here somewhere.
Cool.
So this is the interest rate decision.
So the interest rate decision is probably going to be very much impactful
because first interest rate decision with under Trump.
Interest rate decision has come out in 30 minutes, and then 30.
In the short term, not all the balance of the price shifts bullish.
And there's a long opportunity there for London.
So, yeah, it's fine.
Problem is it's like, where do you try and enter?
If I try to go here, this is also where we go into the market where a lot of
position sizes just become so much larger.
I would be being, I would be being risky with a more aggressive type of stop
loss.
But it's still a 13-pip stop. It's still a large, it's an expectation of a
large move.
Friday the 8th of November, we've already had NFP.
Yeah, I feel like I'm not a huge fan of that, but
it is, whether it is execution time 425.
That's impeccable stop placement, but we still don't really have a chance to
get out to break even.
I would like to go to break even, believe me.
But it's still risk on the table.
And New York session opens and then I'm going to get run straight through on.
Not much you can do.
[silence]
It's still technically bullish.
I know a bearish. I'm not going to get a trade in that time.
This is technically the swing high, which I don't really believe in too much,
but
again, the price action, as you can see, is just not really great.
[silence]
There's just no way.
I don't like this at all.
Three kind of bullback, break a structure.
The M1 is bearish.
If he was a result to internal, the internal break would be here.
If I had to enter, which I'm not really sure I would, I would use that.
So technically considered a discretion given the fact that we have to resort to
internal structure.
That would be a break even, but the management would have to come into here.
You'd definitely break even.
Not a huge one of that trade, to be honest with you.
Well, it's not highest, but I'm favorable.
[silence]
We are technically aligned, but we have to go internal.
Again, you might sometimes find that I'll take a trade that the trade comes
through and it's
profitable, but I don't care about the profitability of the trade.
You'll visibly see that.
What I care about is, and sometimes I might even, when I take a profitable
trade and I'm still sitting here,
I don't like that.
It's because, and this is what you need to understand and adopt, is that I don
't care about results in back testing.
I care about, if I execute this set up a hundred times in the life market, what
's my outcome going to be?
That's it.
I don't care about back testing, I don't want to make money in back testing.
How do I have money in the market? You make money in the market with a good
system, obviously.
Rest management, psychology, et cetera.
I know my risk management is on point.
My trade management, sorry.
It's another one of those, isn't it?
[inaudible]
[silence]
Very weak change of character.
Not a huge fan of that.
That would be flagged for review.
[silence]
What is this perception?
PPI-830, that's PPI.
[silence]
Not a huge fan of this set up either.
It's a good area, it's long from, but there's no setup.
At least we might be getting a little bit of smoother price action.
[silence]
No news, apparently.
I would need this stage of load to be taken out, I think.
Well, I think I would.
It's a cleaner price delivery though, a lot cleaner.
Whoa, choose the naive. No news, but that's a wild.
[silence]
I know it's wonky, but...
Building permits 830, which I don't think is going to have a huge impact.
There's no trade there.
I don't know how I'm supposed to trade that, but I just...
There's no chance I'm going to trade that.
It's untradable.
But we would develop a nice price action here.
[silence]
No news, apparently.
It's been a few of these specific setups that I've been a little bit in terms
of the area that I'm trading from.
Something I've noticed with that specific setup of the kind of low sweep of
continuation in New York.
Sometimes when the continuation doesn't come in the right place, it can be a
great setup,
but I think the principles of the retracement itself need to be looked at.
[silence]
Honestly, for me, again, it would come down to discretion, but that's not a
change of character.
It's not a change of character, not in this context.
There's no trade there for me, and 22nd in November, it's probably going to be
H-CUB.
Yeah, it's H-CUB anyway.
I wouldn't trade it, but still, it's just not a change of character.
But that becomes continuation.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
[silence]
Damn.
That's what you want to see.
You want to see price come into an area, start this, and then go.
I don't know if it's going to be a good setup, but from a principal perspective
, that's what I want to see.
Obviously, there is a lot of self-sided liquidity, to be honest with you,
but it's a much more ideal delivery of price.
Not a huge trend of the stock placement in terms of the liquidity,
and we're kind of just in the middle of nowhere.
Well, I'll meet again in a gap, and most gaps do get filled, and sometimes they
don't get filled all the time.
Kind of 100%, but from a delivery perspective, what you want to see is price.
When you're bullish, you want to see, again, this is ideal.
You want to see price on its way down, be aggressive, and then have this, right
?
You want it to find this area, and then don't be the first mover.
Be the continual mover.
At least, that's like my...
From the hundreds, and hundreds, and hundreds, and hundreds of trades I've
taken,
those always tend to be the better performance trades.
And that's five.
You can see, like, sure, no tag, but you can see, like...
Monday the 25th, IFO.
How do you look at longin' from Glunded Lowes?
It makes sense.
No, it's our context.
And we're bearish.
FOMC at two, FOMC minutes, should I say, and we are bullish again.
We're not going to get a trade off the back of that.
Just, no.
Well, we're bullish again, and that may be a sell.
Yep.
I think we have enough room to trade higher to be able to use this as our entry
.
I could be cheeky and try and put my stop loss a little bit higher,
but is it worth it, really?
Maybe bring my entry down to kind of equilibrium of the inverter I got.
That's what happens when you... Oh, wait.
I didn't come to there anyway.
I was going to say that that's what happens when you think you can outsmart the
market.
I have no idea if we're in profit for this month.
We're not going to trade off the back of that, of course.
Cool. We're bullish, obviously, first of the 28th.
Oh, well, that's 27th.
Cool.
I would take that in the real market, just letting you know.
A lot of this price action I think I've traded.
I think I remember this price action from the end of last year.
I think I remember taking the longs from here, even with the members.
I'm pretty sure of it.
If I'm not mistaken, I'm pretty sure. Yeah, I do. I remember this.
I don't know if it trades from here or lower, but I remember taking the trade
with members.
The model hasn't drastically changed.
I would take this in the live market.
I'm not going to skew the data by taking it and putting it as discretion,
but I obviously would take it because I did take it.
I think it was later in the day.
I think price came.
I think it might have even been from here.
Maybe this data feed tells us something different because I think it was a
sweep of these lows.
Right? I'm pretty sure I remember it's 28th of November.
One of you is from here. I think on my data feed, this here is not a break.
It's a sweep.
Pretty sure I remember taking this trade.
There's M5 or something.
I could be wrong, but I think I remember it.
Was it in New York? I don't think it was in New York.
I think I remember being in the gym in Dubai in the morning, which is like, I
think it's around 11 or something.
I'm not sure.
First of the 28th.
It was in New York.
It may have been technically based off of this data feed anyway.
This is shift bear, so I can't take this long now.
I'm pretty sure I remember taking these longs.
100%. I remember price coming to this age of session high.
Because then Friday, I think we'll cover it.
But yeah, this is independent data, so in different data.
Let's go to London.
I remember these longs.
New York, 29th on the Friday.
Inflation rate.
It's already finished. We can belong from here.
Again, this is where stop-loss sizes just became so significantly higher, and
it hasn't gone back since.
2024, mid to early 2024, like precision like this, you're looking at like three
or four pips.
It was even worse. Not worse, sorry. It was even less in, I think I remember
like 2022, 2023.
Like, genuinely, you're having like five minute order blocks with like two pips
, two pips up, two and a half pips up.
It was ridiculous.
But then obviously the profit targets were also like not as crazy as they are
these days.
Maybe there's just more capital in the markets.
And just to make sure there's not much right after that.
[inaudible]
And that is our year.
2024 year today, it could be typically that's kind of the date range that will
trade.
I guess now it's time for kind of like a detailed data synopsis, so I'll make
that a separate video.